what are the best openings in chess that
I should study this typically comes from
newer players getting into the game
possibly watching a few of the videos
and realizing there's too many different
openings to learn all of them so they
kind of want to narrow it down and
figure out what they should work on
first it also will come from chess
players that maybe they've been playing
for a while but they really only know a
couple openings and they want to figure
out maybe some other ones that are
popular or that maybe may fit their
specific playing style a little bit
better so I thought it'd be cool to go
over the top 10 chest opening things
that I think every chess player should
know they all have different facets to
them some are more for aggressive
players some are more from passive
players they like to Counterattack later
in the game so it has something for
everyone so without further Ado the top
10 chess
openings